How do you see the relationship they have
the link between the generation
younger with Basque politics.
Youth communities have taken 1 certain
decision from 1 aesthetic fascination
or assimilation to the group.
And in those moments,
well, em,
it is clear that Bildu's option is
very affordable for young people.
Well,
they have been trying to work on it,
which also
has greatly moderated its pro-independence discourse,
with which it wins the votes of
of kids or other people who may be
would have been cautious in voting on 1 option of
of rupture.
The fact that there are no attacks,
no violence,
it makes me see.
So,
this is your World of,
you go there with peace of mind.
I vote for whoever convinces me
and that the one who obtains a parliamentary majority governs.
Yes,
there are still open wounds,
but well,
more or less
it is obvious that social ties are being remade.
Feels close to words that are used
both right now
in the public debate,
As identity or nationalism,
no?
Well,
I am very wary of political discourse.
who are naturally on their way to gaining followers.
and to show themselves as the eh the
and present the under 1 opponent Albus unfavorable.
And you, for example,
do you give any importance to having a few
Basque surnames?
Does that provide you with?
No, no,
I give
quite the opposite.
I made fun of this.
I have all the Basque surnames,
but not because
I have chosen it,
if it's not because that's what I notice,
and besides
I like to define myself as 1 man looking for
not to settle in 1 identity,
in traditions
and to repeat them every day.
And I have the last names I have,
but I don't understand them as 1 medal
on the flap,
much less